Trascrizione: Alessia Banka
Revisore: Michele Gianella
I ragazzi di TEDx mi hanno chiesto
di venire a parlarvi
di democrazia digitale.
Ebbene, mi presento.
Sono Porfirio Rubirosa.
Sono un cantautore dadaista.
Le mie canzoni si basano sul paradosso.
Ebbene, io oggi vi darò
prova di un paradosso.
Oggi vi dimostrerò con metodo scientifico,
galileiano, con prove inoppugnabili,
che una bella, sana, vigorosa
e financo virile dittatura
costituisce la base per la fioritura
non solo della democrazia,
ma dell'universale concetto di libertà.
Potremmo persino inventarci uno slogan:
"Dittatura per una democrazia duratura".
Lo so, fa ridere; ma è un'idea
che ho fin da piccolo.
Fin da quando ero bambino,
mio padre era un appassionato di auto.
E di donne.
O forse era un appassionato di donne
e credeva che le auto
fossero il mezzo migliore
per coltivare la sua passione.
Vabbè, fatto sta
che cambiava l'auto ogni anno.
In famiglia non eravamo poveri,
ma nemmeno ricchi;
e quindi le auto doveva,
giocoforza, comprarle usate.
Insomma, comunque il tutto intaccava
i fondi a disposizione della famiglia:
fuori una Alfa Romeo quasi nuova,
dentro una Ariston quasi da buttare.
Mio padre era molto, molto furbo:
riusciva a farti credere
che comprando le auto usate
non abbatteva la svalutazione del nuovo,
e cambiandole spesso,
il valore dell'auto non cambiava.
In più, ti faceva anche credere
che partecipavi attivamente
alla scelta dell'auto.
Tutte balle.
Allora, succedeva così.
Arrivava a casa, ed esordiva con un bel:
"È arrivata l'ora
di cambiare l'auto di famiglia.
E siccome voi fate parte della famiglia,
è giusto che anche voi diciate la vostra".
Allora partivo io, ed entusiasta
proponevo una bella Mercedes.
Mia madre, timidamente,
ci provava con una BMW;
mio padre, marziale, era per l'Audi.
Seguivano giorni e giorni
di valutazioni sui pro e contro:
Mercedes, BMW e Audi.
E alla fine, vediamo se indovinate,
alla fine qual era
l'auto che veniva scelta?
L'Audi.
Quella scelta da mio padre.
Ogni anno, tutti gli anni, la stessa cosa.
Io ci provavo entusiasta,
mia mamma diceva la sua;
e poi alla fine l'auto scelta
era sempre quella di mio padre.
E così, dopo pochi giorni
ci ritrovavamo fuori
una bella Audi 90 color sabbia.
Giuro, una volta ha comperato
un'Audi color sabbia.
Allora, al di là
delle stravaganze cromatiche,
questo racconto che vi ho fatto
è, a mio parere, molto utile
per farci capire meglio i concetti
di democrazia, di rappresentatività
e di partecipazione.
Noi siamo abituati a pensare
che la democrazia sia
il governo del popolo.
Lo certifica il vocabolario.
Ma soprattutto, ci hanno insegnato
che il bello della democrazia
è che tutti sono rappresentati,
all'interno della democrazia.
Tutte le categorie:
ci sono i conservatori,
ci sono i liberali,
c'è qualche radicale,
ci sono tutte le minoranze.
In democrazia - pensate -
c'è spazio persino per gli omofobi,
persino per gli xenofobi.
Insomma, c'è spazio per tutti.
E noi - diciamo - siamo tranquilli
perché vivendo in questa democrazia,
in cui c'è la massima rappresentatività,
riteniamo di poter partecipare
al processo democratico,
meglio ancora se, magari, facendolo
comodamente seduti da casa, con un clic.
Ma siamo proprio sicuri che sia così?
Siamo certi che le cose funzionino così?
Allora, facciamo così:
proviamo a fare un esperimento.
Ci state?
Allora, al mio "tre" dovete pronunciare
la marca della vostra auto.
Non il modello,
mi raccomando, solo la marca.
Al tre, pronti?
Uno, due, tre!
No, non è che ci ho capito moltissimo,
ma è una questione
che non siete partiti tutti a tempo
e magari non avevate
la voce bella stentorea.
Ci riproviamo dai, un'altra volta.
Però quella era la prova,
adesso facciamola bene.
Al tre.
Solo la marca, non il modello.
Pronti?
Uno, due, tre.
(Rumore)
Allora, cerchiamo di capirci.
Mi confermate che siete
seduti in poltrona?
Mi confermate che la poltrona
è sufficientemente comoda?
Potete confermarmi che al mio "tre"
voi avete pronunciato, con voce stentorea,
la marca, e non il modello,
della vostra auto?
E potete confermarmi che, ciononostante,
non si è capito se c'erano BMW,
se c'erano Mercedes, se c'erano Audi -
MM: "Ho detto basta, eravamo d'accordo,
niente marche, lo sapevi dalle mail,
allora l'hai detto una volta,
l'hai detto due volte,
l'hai detto tre volte"
"Matteo?!"
"Niente marche!
Lo si sapeva da 7000 mail
che ci siamo mandati, basta,
cioè adesso cos'è qua?! Il numero uno?!
Stacca pure, accendi le luci.
Lo sapevi benissimo."
MM: "Ok, però -"
"Ok, però c'è un accordo
preso in anticipo."
"Gli facciamo finire il talk almeno?"
"Non ho capito."
"Possiamo fargli finire il talk?
Beh, glielo tagliamo! "
PR: "Non è che l'ho detto
per fare pubblicità. "
"Ci son le telecamere,
il messaggio passa."
Quindi, dai!
"Beh, lo tagliamo dopo,
non ti preoccupare."
"Io avevo precise istruzioni, poi -"
"Non si può. No perché c'è la diretta"
"Sì, preferirei parlarne dopo. Grazie."
"Non posso continuare?
Cioè non posso continuare."
MM: "Lo facciamo continuare? "
"Lo tagliamo dai,
in qualche modo facciamo,
vai pure avanti, grazie."
Quello che avete appena visto
è un esempio concreto
dei concetti di democrazia,
di dittatura e di partecipazione.
In questo senso il drugo Arcureo,
mio compagno di mille incursioni dadaiste,
i ragazzi di TED e Matteo
ci hanno dato una mano.
Era tutta una messinscena.
Forse qualcuno l'ha capito,
forse non lo avete capito;
ma non ha importanza.
Quello che è importante è che quello
che voi avete appena visto
ci ha dato, più di mille parole,
un esempio concreto di alcune dinamiche.
Abbiamo capito
che esprimere la propria opinione
rimanendo seduti in poltrona
ha un'utilità relativa.
Voi avete detto e pronunciato
la marca della vostra auto.
Chi lo ha sentito?
Quasi nessuno.
Solo quelli che erano attorno a voi.
Ma nel marasma complessivo
delle informazioni,
la vostra partecipazione
non è arrivata per davvero.
Voi avete avuto una illusione di libertà,
effimeramente confermata
dalle persone che vi circondano;
ma che nell'economia complessiva,
in questa narrazione liquida,
si disperde.
Ed è talmente liquida
che a un certo punto si asciuga.
Ricorda molto quelle processioni
che a volte si vedono camminare
per i marciapiedi di New York
in cui un piccolo gruppo
sparuto di persone
manifestano per i motivi più disparati.
Gli altri astanti li guardano incuriositi,
e dopo poco riprendono la loro attività,
come nulla fosse.
Giorgio Gaber direbbe
che quei manifestanti
non sono realmente liberi,
ma stanno invece facendo
quello che la libertà vuole
che loro facciano.
Ma vi faccio un altro esempio:
il drugo Arcureo, quando abbiamo fatto
la consultazione per le marche di auto,
nella prima consultazione
ha urlato "Niente marche!"
Chi lo ha sentito?Nessuno.
Nella seconda consultazione,
assieme a voi, lui ha urlato
"Basta! Ti blocco!"
Anche in questo caso,
nessuno lo ha sentito.
Solamente quando lui è arrivato qui,
le cose sono veramente cambiate.
Solamente quando ha messo in campo
una reale azione, le cose sono cambiate.
Potremmo dire che,
in epoca di democrazia digitale,
più di milioni di persone
comodamente sedute in poltrona,
ne vale di più una sola che si alza
ed è in grado di staccare
la spina che alimenta il server.
Naturalmente io non sto dicendo
che il drugo Arcureo,
quando è arrivato qua,
avesse un atteggiamento condivisibile.
È stato un dittatore.
Il suo atteggiamento
è stato dispotico, è stato deprecabile,
e quindi non è questo il punto;
ma la cosa bella è che, dopo di questo,
noi a un certo punto ci siamo coalizzati,
voi vi siete coalizzati insieme
per rovesciare la situazione precedente.
Cioè, insieme avete creato
un gruppo di pensiero compatto.
Per farlo, però,
avete dovuto avere bisogno
di un nemico comune.
E quel nemico comune,
che può essere - di volta
in volta - un dittatore,
può essere il terrorismo,
può essere la pandemia,
è quello che ci unisce.
Bertrand Russell,
in "Autorità ed individuo"
scrive che, quando siamo sull'autobus,
la persona che è seduta accanto a noi
per noi non significa nulla.
Ma se quell'autobus si trova
sotto un bombardamento,
quella persona accanto a noi
diventa nostro fratello.
Allora, se noi capiamo questa dinamica,
se noi siamo in grado di capire
che è lo stimolo quello che ci fa passare
dall'illusione di azione all'azione,
allora possiamo fare
a meno di quello stimolo,
e agire direttamente.
Ma per farlo dobbiamo imparare
a rimettere al centro
una cosa che ormai sta scomparendo.
Ed è il concetto di fatica.
La fatica è un concetto
che sta scomparendo
perché la tecnologia,
come primo nemico giurato, ha la fatica.
Perché la tecnologia ha bisogno di portare
nelle nostre vite la comodità.
Ma dobbiamo imparare
a fare una grande distinzione,
che è la distinzione
tra comodità e benessere.
Non sempre ciò che è comodo
costituisce anche un benessere.
Quindi dobbiamo superare questa differenza
tra azione e illusione di azione.
Io non sto dicendo che la tecnologia
sia sempre sbagliata,
ma dobbiamo distinguere
tra una tecnologia buona
e una tecnologia cattiva.
Dobbiamo capire che non salveremo
la democrazia con un clic.
Così come non salveremo il pianeta
non stampando le e-mail che ci mandano,
o facendo la raccolta differenziata.
Questo è tutta comunicazione,
è tutto talking emozionale,
serve per farci credere
di stare facendo qualche cosa
ma in realtà non stiamo facendo
assolutamente nulla.
Questo è talking emozionale che -
tolta l'enfasi - non rimane nulla.
Circa 100 anni fa, qualcuno disse:
il concetto di libertà, non è assoluto,
perché nulla nella vita vi è di assoluto.
La libertà non è un diritto, è un dovere.
Non è un'elargizione, è una conquista.
Non è un'uguaglianza, è un privilegio.
Il concetto di libertà muta
col passare del tempo.
(Applausi)
Vedete?
Vi siete fatti fregare un'altra volta.
Avete appena applaudito a un concetto,
quello di libertà relativa,
propugnato da Benito Mussolini
all'indomani del delitto Matteotti.
La libertà non è mai un concetto relativo.
La libertà è sempre un concetto assoluto.
(Applausi)